well tuesday marks the 52nd anniversary
of neil armstrong's first steps on the
moon it will
also be the second time in two weeks
that a billionaire will take a
self-funded trip to the edge of space
last week richard branson lifted off
aboard his virgin galactic spacecraft
and now amazon founder jeff bezos is set
to blast off
in a rocket built by his private space
company blue origin
going along for the ride our bezos's
brother mark oliver damon
an 18 year old who will become the
youngest person ever in space
and a trailblazing aviator who many
believe should have made the trip into
space
decades ago bring your wing up
not a girl when i met wally funk back in
2013
her love of flight was infectious clap
your hands
wiggle your wings all right now put your
hand back on the wheel
funk has spent her life among the clouds
she had her first flight lesson at age
nine
became a licensed pilot by the age of
17.
and has logged more than 19 000 flying
hours
but her dream of going to space eluded
her
until now we're going to fly you up into
space on the very first
flight that's your
at the age of 82 funk will be the oldest
person to travel to space when she goes
up on blue origin's
new shepard rocket on tuesday we open
the hatch
and you step outside what's the first
thing you say
i will say honey that was the best thing
that ever happened to me
but her pathway to the stars was not an
easy one
in the 1960s while america's first
astronauts were going through nasa's
rigorous training
funk was part of the mercury 13. a group
of 13 women who went through the same
uncompromising exams we had no idea what
we were going through
we didn't know where it was taking us
x-raying all your body
every bone every tooth sticking
water in your ears i had to drink
radioactive water so these were
painful strenuous uncomfortable tests
yes the women of mercury 13 met and
often surpassed the results of the men
so you went through all these tests was
there any question in your mind that you
would become an astronaut
it was no yeah i knew it would now but
the women would never get their chance
nasa required astronauts to be military
test pilots
and the military at the time didn't
allow women to
fly decades later
american women did find their place at
nasa she definitely was a personal
inspiration to me
including retired astronaut nicole stott
who has spent more than a hundred days
in space
you kind of think about like her paving
the way because it was
some pretty ridiculous stuff all of us
as as women astronauts that
that recognize that we don't get here by
ourselves
you know we are leveraging
every day you know kind of the on wonder
that was put before us
the strength that was put before us for
wally funk the dream
never died it's only now being realized
i'm willing
that is my quest most people would have
given up by now
but i'm not i love flying that's my job
that's what i love
and i'm not a quitter and she made it
happen so she's going up with the
youngest
uh the 18 year old i just wonder
what she is like putting in that young
man's ear
about what he can do with the rest of
his life because she
is just she is such an inspiration i'm
sure she'll
i'm sure she'll say a few things kissing
don't give up on your dream [ __ ] like
the prime example that's beautiful
michelle
gotta love wow